the last topic is an especially touchy
topic Oklahoma City Thunders Josh giddy
goes viral for alleged explicit photos
with an underage girl NBA player Josh
giddy is facing potential statutory rape
allegations after pictures and videos
surface online showing him with an
allegedly underage girl the girl
identified as Liv cook reportedly claims
to have had sexual intercourse with
giddy giddy is 21 years old while cook
is a high school sophomore the age of
consent is 16 meaning that if Cook is 15
giddy would be committing a crime the
date of the pictures and videos is
unclear so it is possible they were
taken before cook turned 16 the Oklahoma
City Thunder has not yet made any public
statements about the allegations over
the past couple of days was some pretty
serious allegations I know nothing
concrete there but is there anything you
can say as to this situation yeah I mean
I understand the question obviously but
um you know there's no right
now I get the question guy I completely
understand you guys want to know about
it but uh just just for right now I
don't every game a small piece of
nightclub footage may be the key that
saves Josh giddy's entire NBA career
from the concerning allegations against
him on Friday evening the NBA confirmed
that they are conducting an
investigation into the serious
allegations that Josh giddy has had a
relationship with an underage girl while
more concerning Clues have leaked online
apart from initial photos and videos the
new video offers a new light into what
could potentially help the Australian
players case a video uploaded by a
random Twitter user shows a moment of
Josh giddy with a girl that seems to be
Liv cook there's only one problem though
cook should not be there if she is
supposed to be a minor after this new
piece of evidence there are new
questions that need to be made first of
all how did Liv cook get into a club
where only adults are allowed did Josh
giddy go into the club knowing he was in
there with an alleged minor is Liv cook
even a minor as the allegation suggest
if that is the case did Liv cook tell
Josh Kitty her real age or did she lie
about it even to him for how long has
Josh giddy known this young woman if we
get around to answering these questions
we will have a less difficult time
getting to the bottom of the truth the
NBA needs to look into these questions
with objectivity and consider all of the
viable options in order to reach the
truth because right now Josh giddy's
career is in serious Jeopardy if for
some reason giddy had no idea this girl
was a minor he may not be looking at a
punishment as severe as he would have if
he knowingly dated this young woman
there's always the possibility that Josh
was tricked into thinking this girl was
over 18 which is quite common amongst
young people at that age but then again
NBA players should not be exposing
themselves in such a manner by dating
young women who seem a little too young
to begin with whatever ends up happening
when the investigations are over someone
will have to pay the price it's also
safe to note that the footage still only
proves nothing only that the allegedly
underage girl was inside a nightclub
illegally you know guys this is an
uncomfortable topic and I think it's an
uncomfortable topic because well no
nobody wants to be labeled I I think the
death of someone's career is to be
labeled a pedo I I don't I can't think
of something worse to call somebody or a
worse reputation to have but my question
is does this young woman bear any
responsibility for that night I mean if
a man at 16 years old Robs a store often
times he's tried as an adult often times
if a kid commits murder at 14 15 years
old they are tried as an adult so in
this case does the young woman bear some
responsibility for hypothetically
tricking a man into thinking that she
was of age is she really a sweet
innocent victim that the left is going
to paint her out to be you know guys
I've been 16 years old before and at 16
I I think you pretty much know what
you're doing this is not me advocating
for relationships between adults and
minors obviously but I I think it's
unfair to put a guy in a situation where
he will have to pay a price when she's
lying about her age allegedly now there
are videos on her Tik Tok account saying
that she is above
[Applause]
18 so in this Tik Tok she's captioning
it that she's over 21 and the question
is if he meets a random girl at a club
that you were supposed to be over the
age of 21 to get into why would he
assume that she's under the age of 21
and I I don't think we can just say
she's an innocent victim in this um and
and I don't really think it's fair to
him that he now has this allegation on
his name that he goes for underage women
I I don't think that's fair